there is some good news among all the
pain and suffering we've shown you for
the past three weeks now a nevada couple
is home after spending 10 days on the
ground in ukraine they hope you can help
them in their mission to give the
ukrainian people a better life in a
completely new country our david sharon
spoke to them from their home in carson
city
i said let's go let's go roll up our
sleeves and help people
and that's exactly what we did army
veteran john staub and his wife lydia
karasinska say it took just seconds to
decide they'd help ukrainian refugees on
the polish border it's really close to
home to me it's very personal personal
because karasinska is from poland and
has friends in ukraine
since the start of war three weeks ago
three million refugees have sought
shelter many in neighboring poland i
don't think anything really
can
describe
even words can describe really what is
going on there photos can give you a
glimpse of what it is like
videos maybe can do better job but
it's really hard to do so
the couple spending 10 days on the
ground taking videos when they could of
the thousands of women and children
trying to flee to safety they slept in
sleeping bags on the ground the
temperature at night falling well below
freezing there is a really big risk of
hypothermia which actually
10 children died
before we got there
so it's
you don't really think about your own
safety when you hear stories like that
they crossed the border 19 times even
spending 11 thousand dollars to buy an
ambulance they say that will help
transport people supplies and food so
it's the duty of us as citizens of the
world
to come to their aid and protect them
through this this terrible conflict now
back in nevada they hope to raise money
for ukrainians who are calling poland
home those forced to leave their lives
behind and create new ones
safe from war
i'm david charns live local now
the couple has started an organization
called ukrainian refugee rescue you can
find a link to help on our website at
8newsnow.com